not a hero is a game from roll seven the
team behind olly olly the incredibly
difficult but fun and challenging
side-scrolling skateboarding game but
not a hero is an action game rather than
a sports game and the story behind it is
a bit ridiculous you as one of I think
about ten characters a lot of which are
unlockable but fighting on behalf of
bunny Lord who is this politician who's
traveled back in time to run for mayor
of the quote-unquote the city and he
wants to win the election so in order to
do that he has got his supporters going
out and fighting crime taking down sort
of the biggest gangsters that are
causing problems for the city
so as you play the game you go through
missions that are filled with various
buildings and one of the biggest and
most important mechanics is cover and
shooting so what you do is you sort of
run enter buildings but you use the a
button to slide from object to object
and your character will automatically
pop and hide behind cover then you then
you know jump out when it's appropriate
to shoot enemies not a hero is a very
fast paced game and by completing
certain challenges that are tied to
performance you unlock stuff so you do
want to play quickly and with a lot of
skill and that can you know depend a lot
on the character you choose some are
slow some are fast some can't use
secondary items but they have really
strong melee attacks some can combine
attack such as sliding and firing at the
same time and all these characters have
pretty funny qualities there's one guy
Jesus or he soos
although the devs call him Jesus he's
loosely modeled after the Jesus from The
Big Lebowski
he's a open shirt wearing guy with a
gold necklace who does a lot of air
thrusting and humping for his idol
animation he's very quick and pretty
funny to play as there's another guy who
is a sort of middle aged man who has
failed at life and now he dons a
superhero masking cape and he's pretty
slow but he says a lot of really funny
things and it's sort of a goal for
people who are trying to play the game
in a different way to test their skill
there are a lot of secondary items to
use in the game that help you strategize
such as grenades and such but grenades
with different behavior and in that
sense it's a little bit like worms when
it comes to the weapon selection things
are absurd but they also have a
strategic element that's very important
to consider not a hero does leave a lot
of room for players who want to be
really good at the game too
practice and come up with their own
strategies and while you can play you
know sort of a stealth heavy game if
you'd like you can also run a gun and
depending on the character you choose
that will make things a little bit more
difficult so trying out the entire cast
familiarizing yourself with their
abilities is pretty important no matter
how you really want to play the game
because ultimately in order to beat it
you're going to have to be good and so
you're gonna have to focus on one style
of play or another at first so not a
hero is coming to PC and early May which
is not too far off and the team recently
updated the build to run at 60 frames
per second and this goes aligned with
this sort of twitch fast paced gameplay
that it's been designed to support so
keep an eye out for not a hero if you
appreciate fast action games and pixel
art style and it will be coming to
PlayStation down the road